- Rachel Lapierre a fondé
-abris dans l'urgence.
Elle consacre ses journées aux
toxiquées et esseulées.
- Papi, papi, tu le sais que
je t'aime. Tu le sais qu'on va-!
- Durant la pandémie,
elle ajoute une halte à
suggéré par la ville.
RACHEL LAPIERRE, présidente et
- Les gens arrivent, prennent
un repas, peuvent utiliser
la toilette, se déposent.
bottes mouillées, leurs bas
mouillés. S'ils ont un problt ue
de santé, il y a un téléphone
qui va se faire vers moi.
de personnes viennent ici,
ils sontt 80 sans-
abris à fréquenter l'endroit,
car peu d'organismes dans
à cette clientèle.
r, il n'y a pas
de sallea de bains dans
pas de toilettes, donc les gens
dans les cours
des voisins faire leur besoin.
reçu de nombreuses plaintesdu ve
un sentiment de compassion
- On essaie de pas trop brasser
les choses, puis en même temps,
bien on est frustré par ce que
un été à entendre crier tout
l'été. Tout ce qu'on espère
c'est qu'ils vont se trouver
les laisser dehors.
- Je pense que ça dépasse
ce qu'elle peut offrir
- Le Book Humanitaire a été
expulsé par la Ville, il doit
quitter les lieux d'ici samedi.k
Humanitaire, je ne sais pas
où je serais.
- Bien, je ne peux pas recevoir,
je ne peux pas les voir...
"Allez viens chez nous",
je suis dans la rue... c'est sûs
et se sont installés dansles bo.
- On va y aller cas par cas.
On va voir. On va tout mettre
en place, en tout cas,
pour s'assurer au moins
de leur sécurité.
- La Ville de Saint-Jérôme
n'a pas réagi et le CISSS
des Laurentides nous expliqu
que plusieurs organismes
ajustent leur offre de service
pour répondre aux besoins
dans la région.
Ici, Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, Mon